You know how you go from partner to get through stuff
to partner that put you through stuff
is the dude starts to fucking treat you like shit
the minute you have their kid.
They think, oh,
she's stuck. Stuck now.
Now I can really get comfortable.
I could really let loose.
And they let it all hang out.
So that's exactly how you get to that fucking point.
And that's exactly how you get to, okay,
motherfucker,
it's been 10 years.
I've been doing my fucking everything.
I'm exhausted in every fucking way.
I've gone to the doctor now to test me
to see if I'm fucking crazy.
I've been taking every supplement you can think of.
The problem isn't fucking me.
Why don't we try this one?
And then magically let's through.
Look through the fucking comments,
because magically,
magically, the problem is fixed. So, yeah,
that's how you get from partner to get through stuff
with to partner that put you through stuff.